thank you so much brother very delighted
to to have you on the program i'm very
excited
greetings of peace you are watching the
d show which is a way of life we try to
put out there for
everyone to see helping you understand
islam and muslims
have you heard of arthur wagner well
he's coming up next
this is the far right politician
who accepted islam he's our guest
on the show you want to know why well
you're going to find out why
why did he accept islam someone who was
working hard against islam
a party that opposed islam and then he
accepted islam what is islam
you're going to find that out also here
on the dean show don't go anywhere
are you ready
[Music]
you guys have all heard of our brother
who's on the show
he was with the political party from
germany
that was really working hard spreading
misinformation about islam and
really many people were not educated
about islam but our brother arthur he
got educated he connected with some
muslims
and we want to hear his story how you
fight you you ended up i mean is this
true you ended up accepting islam
uh [ __ ] brother i have converted
to islam in october uh
uh 2017 in bashkirian
this is a small republic muslim republic
in russia
but i have a feeling for orient
and islam since my born i like it islam
but i thought this is a wonderful thing
but not for me this is for others and uh
two years ago i was first time in mosque
in barcelona and i asked the
man there what is islam and he sent me a
please
give this please read these books think
about it
and two years later in
october 2017 i have decided and i am
muslim now and i am really happy this is
a wonderful life
to be a muslim you are my brother i hope
one day to meet you i'm so excited
how do you feel being embraced you have
over 1.7 billion
family members now do you feel the love
but you do not believe i have now in my
facebook
a lot of friends and i understood
what uh is to be muslim i understood
a lot of things and i i am
i i i i i like allah
i have a feeling that he helped me
uh and uh i am very very
i was ill uh seven years
three years ago and now i do not smoke i
don't drink
i make sport my wife is really happy
my daughter is happy uh my father is
happy
i miss that's very good so yeah muslim
is very good
so your family they've uh they've
respected your decision that you made
yes because they saw uh how i am changed
and i'm changed positive and i say if
you are muslim
you are positive guy i never thought
this
again uh that's a couple of years ago
and now i know it's why
tell us how so people can understand
because from what we know
educate us help us understand you are
part or still are
a part of this afd that's the
alternative for
democracy and or something what does afd
stand for
alternative for germany so what was the
model
is this correct that they uh the the
the um party there their slogan was
is uh germany has no place for islam or
islam has no place in germany
yeah no no no no no that slogan was the
islam
not belong to germany oh okay i
i am a big friend from islam since years
and i said the people do not believe
do not trust to god that people do not
trust to
uh do do not understand what is uh
be the muslims and they say islam belong
not to
germany this is not not correct
because islam cannot be belong or not
belong
islam is wonderful uh creating from
allah and for example took turkey
belonged to islam that's correct and
i never said about this slogan and i
said okay my party is some crazy in this
thing
but now this is clear this is difficult
to be a part of
my party but i believe because i am in
this party
mind party with we're thinking about it
what is islam yes it's very difficult
for the people they are not
in not muslim to speak about islam and i
can do it because i am convert
this is very important to uh be
the convert man because i can speak
in the language which understoodable
from the people which are not muslims
i will speak for islam in my party
and allah will say is correct or not to
erect
inshallah maybe i have a chance to give
their knowledge about islam to my party
i don't
know do you think because when you say
allah how do you say
god in german is it good in god in
german i say
god but uh now for me
uh is more more uh big pleasure to say
allah
because i have a feeling for this one
yes it's
yes yes i say creator sometimes because
you must explain the people which are
not muslims
about our uh creator about allah what he
has done to all people in the world
because many i must say because many
people they have a misconception when
you say allah
this is just god this is just the
almighty god the creator that's it
you're not worshiping this very
interesting point right
because of the church in germany we have
something crazy job the evangelist
church i have
i was today in the organization and i
create i said to organization i am not
more the part of
evangelist church i'm not more the part
of church i cannot be a part of church
but by church some people understand
that
god from uh youth from uh muslims and
from christians is
one god as allah and this is for me was
for correct clear we have one god one
god yes
and we have our prophet uh muhammad
and we have one god but some people some
creep
okay chris i would not say some militant
decrees they say
no no no we have only one god
they're crazy that's really crazy
so now does you i mean do you know when
we talk about jesus many christians
you know they don't know that you still
love jesus you just
as a messenger as a prophet that's it
and do you feel many people i know in my
experience when i talk to people and i
tell them this they shocked they you
know surprised because many people
they are they already you know uh
believe that you know
more with islam that he was a messenger
of god like abraham like moses like
muhammad
yes this was for me a wonderful feeling
i i read quran since three months
i am now the surah 6 and
i will say each word what i have wrote
in quran
is correct and i wrote about
isa and jesus christ and this is
wonderful sentences about this man this
was wonderful prophet and
all what he uh spoke was correct
from your views before what made a
difference was it you connecting with
muslims
reading the quran all these things
together what made
the biggest change and what advice would
you give
for other people who were in your shoes
as many people there's so many
misconceptions
but when we see people connect with
muslims when they open up the quran
when they don't go to you know
islamophobes when they come to us
you know they come and they sit with us
you know then
you know the heart softens and their if
their mind is open
so many good things can happen what was
it with you what was it with you
that had you you know changed this way
the principle was for me
i have understood i have really
understood
what kind of problem had the muslims in
german
i never thought about it i never thought
what kind of
problem have the muslims in europe and
because of this i create now
uh the big uh organization which will
have
the islam in europe the second one
i have understood what is wonderful
feeling
to be
to
is very important for me yes i
understand
uh god created allah so like in islam
and because of this i'm now really
sure in my feeling to walk
to speak with people uh to be with my
family i have more more time for my
family and that's very important for me
yeah
and i learned to speak truth
i cannot lie this is new
yes because i understand if i'm lying
we have uh we will have a problem yes
this is feeling to be clean my very big
friend
said to me islam
gives you cleaning for your soul yes and
for your earned for your for your body
yeah i am the service that's correct
you'll be clean and
body and your soul wonderful
ahmed tell us do you feel now because
the the party that you are with the
conservative party
there is not much different i mean there
are obviously you know a lot of
commonalities
isn't there um okay
i have a dream i have a dream i'm 100
sure that conservative in all worlds
have understanding for islam because
they have
a similar thinking
islam and conservative i'm national
conservative
and i'm muslim german muslims european
muslims
i do not have any problem with
conservatives
like muslims but conservative national
conservatives
sometimes uh crazy they do not
understand what islam is and i would
like to explain this
i will now write a lot of information
and to send this information and i will
speak a lot
to explain the national conservatives
what islam is islam is very good
there's uh something that you said it's
very interesting
that you you didn't change you know they
changed and
in one minute over 50 people started to
hate you you
know yes this is unbelievable i'm very
open guy
i'm very happy i do not have any problem
with people
and my friends in one minute
said to me
just like that in one minute they you
all these friends
in all your whole life that's it they
just because of this decision to worship
the creator not the creation
that's what islam is to worship the
creator allah and not the creation
that's the main message because you did
this that's it
yeah but i do not i lose all people i
lost uh
maybe 20 but i never thought i
that i will lose these people yeah and
other people where i didn't
know that they are good people they come
to me
uh and i have small changing in my life
but
i i really like this change it's very
very good wonderful i have learned in
the last two weeks a lot
what about what what advice do you have
for people who are
in the same position as you in a
conservative you know far-right party
and they're working hard you know with
this hate you know in their hearts
and now you came from that side and now
you're a muslim you accepted islam
they're listening what advice do you
have for them uh you will never believe
i i i i'm really surprised i have a lot
of emails
from conservative international
conservative muslims to me
they say also ahmed
you are wonderful guy thank you very
much we can now
speak about it open that we are muslims
for me it is a very new feeling we have
a we had a problem here i never said
that we have a problem
i said we are in a free country and we
can
open say i am muslims where's the
problem
uh now i would like to say following
please give me a chance
to think about it i need two or three
weeks
to think and i found the salute i
i found the solution how to explain
the conservative muslim is a very good
this is
this is good sorry my english is
submitted correct no no no it's good
yeah so thank you so much we really
appreciate it we wanted to
you know meet you inshallah god willing
we can meet you in person one day
congratulations you know uh we wanted to
also introduce our audience to you we
are so happy elated you know that your
decision and may allah the creator
continue to bless you
and help you in your endeavors in your
in your life
it was a pleasure to speak to you and uh
for all muslims america i am appreciated
to speak to you inshallah if you if have
you been to
america have you been over here on this
side i will inform you i will go to
america clear
and for me inshallah we can have you
inside the studio and we can meet in
person inshallah
thank you very much thank you my brother
thank you did you see that guys did you
did you feel that
the emotion that was behind
i mean he made an intellectual decision
but now
the emotions that encompass this man the
love
that is encompassing him the peace that
is encompassing him
why why is that ask yourself you know
the hate that once
filled a person's heart let's say now
it's overcome
with love he wants to help other people
connect more with muslims he wants to
help
to unify not to divide what are you
doing
if you're not a friend but a foe why
would you want to be a foe
rather than a friend even if you chose
not to accept islam like he did why are
you working hard against it
why this is an intellectual man arthur
ahmed why he thought things through
he's your colleague he was yesterday
with you you know what kind of
individual he is but you just can't help
if
you see what god almighty does he looks
in the hearts of the people and if he
sees good there if he sees genuine good
in your heart
and you're seeking to know the truth
then the creator of the heavens and
earth
god allah will guide you to that truth
you got to be courageous enough like
arthur look at
what he has to lose now a lot but god
replaced those
50 20 30 friends with a family of over
1.7 billion
you might be lonely you might be falling
into despair
but don't despair because there is a way
of life god loves you
and this is islam it shows you the
blueprint for life
that's why arthur accepted it it's a
simple way of life
to submit your will pay attention to the
will of the creator who made you
do you love jesus well islam shows you
how to love jesus
not as a god many people confused about
that
in a trinity but he is absolutely one
god and he sent jesus
as a messenger of god yes that connected
with arthur also
did someone die for your sins no you're
responsible you for yourself
just as i'm responsible for myself
and everyone is born on original
goodness so
the belief system of islam is something
that's
rational logical it makes sense that god
almighty allah the one who created you
is a one and alone worthy of worship can
you dig
that can you understand that it's simple
to comprehend
and that connected with arthur and it
will connect with you
the only one that has to lose is you if
you keep a closed mind
so now you've opened it it's working
open your heart
and look the same way arthur
wagner looked into islam look at it i'm
giving you just a little taste test
the worship of the creator not the
creation and god almighty out of his
love he sent these messengers you know
about him
abraham moses noah
jesus the list goes on muhammad just
being peace be upon them all the last
and final messenger
and they came with the same not
contradictory messages
god doesn't do unwise foolish things
he sent the same persistent message
since the beginning
submit your will to the will of the
creator
do what god wants you to do and in one
word that's
islam my friends and a muslim like what
arthur wagner is now is one
who submits themselves to the creator
man or woman
and that's what jesus did did he submit
to himself did he worship himself no
we love jesus he submitted to god he
prayed to god
same as moses and abraham and our
messenger
till the end of time is prophet muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him and they
came with this guidance
and we have it preserved tamper-free
temporal proof
in the quran the verbatim word of god
and as you can see arthur he was very
excited
to dwell into the quran now depending
how you come at it
if you come at it with a scandalous
heart looking for trouble what are you
going to get
you're only going to deceive yourself
but do
what arthur did he had an open heart he
connected with muslims
genuinely looking for the truth he
believed in god he believes in these
these values that were taught by all the
messengers that god almighty sent
there's a lot to talk about but i'm sure
if you're honest with yourself
the few things that i've said of the
teachings of islam
if you can connect with these things all
of these other things are easy
prayer fasting charity easy
ease easy modesty
morals well good manners ethics easy
easy it might be difficult subduing your
desires for some things
but with god's help you can see the
positive change that arthur's made and
if you've been part of his party
you know the man since yesterday now
know the
updated new version of arthur happy at
peace because he connected with the
owner of peace
the one who created him the one who
created you now you can turn your back
what are you going to do then so we're
here to help
we're here to help and we brought you
this story
i hope you enjoyed thank you very much
tune in every week to the dean show if
you haven't subscribed why haven't you
right now do it thank you very much
assalamu alaikum peace be with you
i'm your brother yes salaam alaikum